ils viennent par dizaines chaque fin de
semaine sur la plage var sauva deux
bombes et armes et de tracteurs et de
camions ils déterrent déchets et résidus
de plastique 12 tonnes d'ordures sont
retirés du sable à chaque opération de
nettoyage
l'avocat approche a lancé le mouvement
il ya six ans tout a commencé parce
qu'il voulait faire sa part pour
l'environnement en ramassant des déchets
avec un ami au ministre y compris mais
les océans nous demandent de les aider
ils les nettoyer black t-il son énergie
et sa détermination inspire un nombre
croissant de bénévoles l'échelle cette
femme participe aux corvées de nettoyage
depuis quatre ans elle dit le faire pour
les générations futures
grâce aux efforts d'affranchir la plage
versement n'est plus là plus polluées du
monde
ce qui a commencé par une initiative
locale est maintenant devenu un
mouvement planétaire
les images saisissantes de la
transformation de la plage ont fait le
tour du monde
le programme des nations unies pour
l'environnement considère ce mouvement
citoyen comme étant la plus importante
campagne de nettoyage de plages du monde
cinq mille tonnes de détritus ont été
retirés de la plage va recevoir depuis
l'an passé pour la première fois en
vingt ans les bébés tortues étaient de
retour à frêche à lui a participé ces
dernières années à des campagnes de
nettoyage semblable à vancouver est
assurée en colombie-britannique la
différence du tilt c'est qu'au canada
vous devez retirer des particules de
micro plastiques de l'eau et des plages
ses produits sont encore plus toxique
que les gros déchets ici à bombay sur la
plage de vars oeuvres à l'étape suivante
de la campagne citoyenne sensibiliser
les bénévoles à modifier leurs habitudes
de consommation
ce texte un bayou et bonifacio
on aide un des pays les plus pollués de
la planète
une nouvelle génération se mobilisent et
fait de l'écologie une priorité il sait
philippe leblanc radio-canada bombay